eeuu alcanzó otro hito oscuro al superar
las 700 mil muertes por kobe 19
esto significa que 100.000
estadounidenses han sucumbido al virus
desde mediados de junio en enero de 2021
los fallecimientos relacionados por el
hobbit 19 alcanzaron un máximo de 3.000
diarios en junio se redujeron a unos 300
para que las cifras volvieran a casi
2000 muertes diarias este último aumento
se ha atribuido en parte a la
prevalencia de la variante delta del
virus pero también a una ralentización
de la vacunación durante el verano sólo
alrededor del 56% de los estadounidenses
han recibido ambas dosis y los datos
muestran que la mayoría de muertes se
produjeron entre los no vacunados los
estados sureños se han visto
especialmente afectados florida y texas
tienen la tasa de mortalidad más alta
del país con diferencia y mientras que
las hospitalizaciones y contagios han
comenzado a disminuir en las últimas
semanas los expertos advierten que en
los meses de invierno podría haber otro
aumento es probable que las bajas
temperaturas obliguen a las personas a
permanecer en interiores haciéndolas más
vulnerables a contagios y la llegada de
la temporada de gripe podría tensionar
aún más al sistema sanitario
el kobe 19 ya causó más fallecimientos
en eeuu que la gripe española de 1918
algo que hace que sea la pandemia más
mortífera de la historia del país